good morning heck it's tuesday you told
me once that bad news tends to happen
all at once catastrophic events sudden
losses dramatic reversals
whereas good news often happens slowly
well here's some good news happening
slowly the sun
is setting here on the western shores of
lake michigan
known in these parts as america's third
coast i just read a wonderful book by
julia baird called phosphorescence
in which she writes about the importance
of savoring experiences
taking the time to really enjoy
something
like to really taste an oreo or to
really
watch a sunset baird cites several
studies linking savoring to well-being
and that does align with my experience
i've had
years where many wonderful things
happened that i found impossible to
enjoy or even
meaningfully take in because i lacked
the time
or psychological well-being to properly
savor them
and then i've had days like this one
where i am well enough and
moving slowly enough to savor the simple
and
routine wonders that are always around
me
like the sunset the one daily phenomenon
that for me anyway
never gets old like most things savoring
takes practice
it also takes time slow time
thick time the kind of time that is
required to see the good
things that do not happen all at once
this is it must be said
not what youtube is known for being best
at for years i've edited nearly every
breath out of my videos because in this
hyper-distracted information landscape
even a half-second pause is often enough
for someone to think
i should check out one of the other 72
tabs i have open
but here is a breath take it with me if
you can
i've spent a lot of my life thinking and
writing about how we go on
especially in the context of mental
health challenges
but of course how we go on is profoundly
linked
to why we go on we go on because despair
may be powerful
but it's untrue there is light in front
of us
in front of all of us we go on to help
those we love
including those we don't know but still
love
and those who aren't here yet but will
be someday
and we go on because life is beautiful
because our lungs were made for this air
life isn't merely beautiful of course it
is also awful and painful
and unjust and much else but none of
that can negate its beauty
or the gifts to be found in savoring
that beauty
so much of the time i'm obsessed with
what's next and with feeling busy and
feeling like i need to be deeply engaged
with the quickening pulse of the right
now
like if you go to twitter before you
write anything in the box the box says
what's happening and i've long wanted to
know
what was happening i've wanted in truth
to be
part of what was happening but so much
of what's happening isn't
happening fast it isn't news or
even new nobody's tweeting about it
it's water rolling in and rolling out
the sun setting and rising lives
being lived i wish you could be here
hank
not just for the sight of it but to
smell the pine trees
to feel the wind on your skin but then
it occurs to me
that wherever you are there is also air
and sunshine
and the sun will set tonight and i hope
you have a few moments to savor it
hank i'll see you on friday